Trascrizione: Maria Pericleous
Revisore: Chiara Polesinanti
La ricerca scientifica
è il motore della scienza
ed è l’unica arma che ci tirerà fuori
da questa pandemia in modo definitivo.
Parlo della Covid-19.
Torniamo indietro di un anno circa,
realizziamo quello che assomiglia
quasi a un miracolo:
in meno di un mese
è stato identificato e sequenziato
un nuovo virus
che causava una nuova malattia.
In meno di un anno
siamo riusciti ad avere
vaccini altamente innovativi
e parimenti altamente efficaci
nel prevenire la morte e la malattia
e anche molto efficaci
nel prevenire la trasmissione del virus
da un individuo a un altro.
Allora quello che vorrei
provare a trasmettere
è che queste cose non accadono per caso.
Detto in altre parole, questi vaccini --
parlando solo dei vaccini --
non sono nati ieri,
e sono anzi nati per uno scopo diverso.
Sono nati essenzialmente nel concetto
delle terapie personalizzate
per malati di cancro.
L’idea, come vedete nello schema,
è di estrarre l’informazione genetica
dal cancro, da un tumore maligno
di una persona,
per ricavarne in termini di DNA
o di RNA messaggero, diciamo,
delle piccole proteine,
dei peptidi specifici
per quel cancro e quella persona
per indurre, stimolare
risposte immunitarie altamente selettive,
nell’ottica appunto
della terapia personalizzata.
Ma facciamo ancora un passo indietro.
Da dove nasce tutto questo,
almeno parte di questa storia?
Nasce con una storia umana appassionante,
quella di una giovane Ungherese,
Katalin Karikó,
che aveva un’idea un po’ pazza --
oggi diremmo un po’ alla Elon Musk,
per intenderci --
di sfruttare l’RNA
per creare nuovi vaccini.
Per la conoscenza di allora
questa è una specie di eresia,
perché si sa che l’RNA
messo in una cellula
viene degradata nel giro di pochi minuti.
Eppure...
Tant’è che la preoccupazione di Katalin
era quella di trovare una borsa di studio
per arrivare a fine mese.
Finalmente incontra un americano,
Drew Weissman, a Philadelphia,
che sposa l’idea.
Insieme, dopo ovviamente molta ricerca,
pubblicano un articolo scientifico
fondamentale, nel 2005,
che dimostra come
modificando le molecole di RNA,
queste possono essere effettivamente
usate come nuovi vaccini.
Questo lavoro, detto per inciso, potrebbe
conferire il premio Nobel per la medicina
a questi due pionieri.
Tre anni dopo, in Germania,
nasce una piccola azienda BioNtech.
È fondata da Özlem Türeci
e suo marito Ugur Sahin,
entrambi di origine turca,
anche se cresciuti in Germania.
E sfruttando l’idea originale
dell’RNA messaggero
la trasformano in un prodotto
diciamo biotecnologico industriale.
E quando arriva la chiamata del Covid,
l’appello globale internazionale
per scoprire i vaccini,
fanno alleanza
con la multinazionale Pfizer
e producono il primo vaccino efficace
basato sull’RNA messaggero --
se ne aggiungeranno poi altri --
che tutti noi, o molti di noi,
hanno avuto come inoculazione.
Tutto questo ci porta
a una domanda di base.
Come funziona la scienza?
Cioè come è possibile
che queste conoscenze, alla fine,
si traducano in cose utili per tutti?
Allora qui dobbiamo distinguere
un prima e un dopo.
Un prima la pandemia
e dopo o durante la pandemia
perché prima, fondamentalmente
la scienza funzionava,
semplificando un po’, in questo modo:
immaginatevi, come dire,
un grande crogiuolo di ricerca di base
che produce appunto lavori scientifici
con dati, statistiche, analisi,
che vengono mandate
alle riviste specializzate,
le riviste internazionali scientifiche.
Però questi, prima di essere pubblicati,
vengono vagliati
da altri esperti indipendenti,
quelli detti “peers”, cioè pari,
e solo dopo il loro vaglio,
dopo eventualmente correzioni
chieste dai “peers”,
queste conoscenze diventano
effettivamente un articolo scientifico.
Un articolo scientifico
che noi potremmo definire
il mattoncino Lego della scienza,
della conoscenza.
E ovviamente in ogni settore
ci sono tanti mattoncini Lego
che alla fine raggiungono l’obiettivo.
Un ulteriore elemento
è che come in tutti i campionati sportivi,
per esempio nel campionato di calcio,
esistono riviste scientifiche top
e riviste scientifiche di minor livello.
Quindi anche in quale rivista scientifica
un articolo è pubblicato
conferisce una potenziale importanza
a quella, chiamiamola scoperta,
o comunque quelle nuove informazioni.
Che cosa è cambiato
in questi due anni di pandemia?
L’ultimo elemento è
che tutto questo processo richiede tempo,
un tempo medio che potremo stimare
tra uno, due, tre anni.
Stavo dicendo che cosa è cambiato
con la pandemia.
Fondamentalmente quello che è cambiato
sono cambiati due aspetti fondamentali.
Il primo riguarda la comunità scientifica,
perché quegli articoli
che prima venivano mandati,
in modo, come dire, non conosciuto ai più,
alle riviste per pubblicazioni,
oggi vengono depositati
su piattaforme specifiche.
E questo ha avuto un enorme impatto,
per esempio sulla pandemia di Covid,
perché ha permesso a tutta
la comunità scientifica globale
di venire a conoscenza di dati
che avrebbero richiesto
mesi e mesi, se non anni,
prima di essere pubblicati.
Purtroppo, essendo lavori
ancora non vagliati da altri esperti,
a volte è capitato
che siano lavori imperfetti,
e in qualche caso purtroppo
anche lavori falsi.
Il secondo macro aspetto
che ha caratterizzato questo periodo
è stata la ribalta degli esperti,
in senso lato,
che hanno scritto sui giornali,
ma soprattutto hanno occupato
i social network
e i vari format televisivi,
in particolare i talk show.
Questo combinato disposto,
potremmo definire, di deposito di articoli
prima del vaglio scientifico
e di comunicazione diretta tra gli esperti
ha finito per così dire per relegare
l’articolo scientifico pubblicato,
il mattoncino Lego della conoscenza,
a un ruolo quasi marginale.
E la tempistica, come ho detto
con aspetti positivi ma anche negativi,
a volte addirittura ha azzerato
i tempi di trasmissione
dal mondo della ricerca scientifica
alla società civile.
E quali sono quindi le implicazioni
di quello che stiamo ancora
vivendo di fatto?
Le implicazioni che,
l’abbiamo visto un po’ tutti,
molto spesso dal dibattito scientifico
si è passati a un dibattito
di tipo ideologico.
Vi ricorderete tutti i pessimisti
o gli ottimisti dell’anno scorso
sulla fine della pandemia.
E dal dibattito ideologico
molto spesso sono stati aspirati
e sono diventati elementi
di schieramenti politici.
E questo ha finito per la società civile
nell’ingenerare una seconda pandemia
parallela e sovrapposta alla prima,
una pandemia che chiamiamo
tecnicamente “infodemia”.
Cos’è l’infodemia?
Chiediamolo alla Treccani.
La Treccani la definisce: “La circolazione
di una quantità eccessiva di informazioni,
talvolta non vagliate con accuratezza,
che rendono difficile orientarsi
su un determinato argomento
per la difficoltà di individuare
le fonti autorevoli o affidabili”.
Noi potremmo dirlo sostanzialmente
che si tratta di un mix,
qualche volta infernale,
di informazioni scientifiche
e pseudoscientifiche o non validate
quando addirittura non false,
le famose fake news.
E ripeto, questo
ha avuto molto a che fare,
ha molto a che fare
con la logica del talk show.
Perché la logica del talk show,
per la sua struttura, per la sua natura,
prevede che ci siano
due ipotesi bilanciate
che si affrontano,
e non vince quasi mai,
o non necessariamente,
chi ha le argomentazioni migliori,
chi ha le evidenze più solide.
Vince, e lo sapete benissimo,
chi ha la battuta più pronta,
chi è più aggressivo, più carismatico,
alla fine chi sovrasta l’altro.
Ebbene,
la scienza non è compatibile
con una logica da talk show.
Allora facciamo un passo indietro
di un anno esatto
prima dello scoppio della pandemia.
Perché un anno esatto prima
nasce il patto trasversale per la scienza.
Nasce il patto trasversale per la scienza
e chiede a tutte le forze politiche,
senza distinzione,
di sostenere la scienza
come valore universale di progresso,
senza alcun colore politico.
Contestualmente chiede
alla classe politica
di non sostenere la pseudoscienza
e la pseudomedicina,
e di implementare
programmi di informazione,
formazione ed educazione alla scienza
a partire dalla scuola
dell’obbligo in poi,
e infine di assicurare adeguati
finanziamenti pubblici
alla ricerca scientifica.
Ma nello specifico, cosa ha fatto
il patto trasversale
per arginare o contrastare l’infodemia?
Abbiamo fatto un decalogo
di autodisciplina,
chiaramente indirizzato innanzitutto
agli affiliati del patto
trasversale per la scienza,
ma a disposizione di tutta
la comunità scientifica di esperti
che se ne volessero avvalere.
Vediamo rapidamente questi dieci punti.
Il primo punto è la trasparenza,
con riferimento in particolare
alla possibilità
di avere conflitti di interessi
in ambito scientifico.
Il conflitto di interesse, attenzione,
non è né un reato né una cosa negativa.
Però l’importante è che se un cittadino
sta ascoltando un esperto,
sappia che se l’argomento
di cui tratta l’esperto
ha a che fare anche
con i suoi interessi specifici,
questo è bene, deve essere appunto noto,
che è anche una garanzia
per l’esperto stesso
di dichiarare i propri interessi.
A ciascuno il suo.
Voi lo sapete, quasi tutti
gli esperti che vanno in tv
vengono etichettati come virologi.
Ebbene, dovete sapere che un virologo
ha delle competenze diverse
da un immunologo,
complementari ma diverse,
ed entrambi hanno competenze
diverse e complementari
a un infettivologo, e così via.
Credo che nessuna delle persone
che sono qui oggi,
se avesse bisogno di un lavoro in casa
sbaglierebbe nel chiamare
un imbianchino o un idraulico,
un elettricista o un muratore.
Bene, anche nella scienza
è la stessa cosa.
Ognuno ha delle proprie competenze
che poi messe insieme,
magari, si aiutano l’uno con l’altro.
Non improvvisare.
Cercare di conoscere in anticipo
i temi e le domande che verranno fatte,
per essere più preparati,
per non improvvisare, appunto.
No al sensazionalismo.
La scienza non ha bisogno
di gonfiare le proprie osservazioni,
perché queste fatalmente
finiscono per alimentare aspettative,
soprattutto nelle persone o malati,
o con familiari malati,
e poi quando queste aspettative
non vengono confermate dalla realtà,
il tutto finisce
in una sfiducia nella scienza.
Prima i dati scientifici
e poi le opinioni.
Quello che l’esperto dovrebbe fare,
principalmente se non esclusivamente,
è quello di spiegare
in parole semplici ma corrette
i contenuti e i limiti
dei lavori scientifici
o degli studi clinici,
e poi eventualmente dare una propria
opinione sulle ricadute a lungo termine,
ma tenendo molto ben separate
entrambe le comunicazioni.
No alla par condicio.
L’abbiamo detto,
come nella logica del talk show,
nella scienza non esistono quasi mai
due ipotesi uguali che si affrontano.
Esiste un accumulo
di conoscenze consolidate
e poi c’è un’area
in continuo sviluppo e divenire
che va comunicato.
Evitare le polemiche.
Le polemiche non servono assolutamente
a chiarire le idee ma a confondere.
Aggiornamento continuo.
La scienza, l’abbiamo detto anche prima,
è in rapido evolversi, in particolare
per quanto riguarda la pandemia,
e quindi a volte succede anche
che alcune conoscenze
rimpiazzino o sostituiscano o smentiscano
quelle precedentemente accumulate.
Ecco, questo l’esperto deve spiegare
in modo semplice e corretto,
perché secondo le conoscenze di un tempo
predominava una certa idea
e perché oggi magari
ne predomina un’ altra.
Nessuna strumentalizzazione.
La scienza è un patrimonio
di tutta la società
e non solo di una sua parte.
E infine, l’ultimo punto del decalogo
è ammettere i propri errori,
perché tutti sbagliano,
e ricordarsi anche di saper dire
“questo non lo so”.
Cosa possiamo concludere
nella logica del “more no more”?
Possiamo concludere
che la pandemia di Covid
di nuovo ha fatto apprezzare a tutti
l’importanza della scienza
e delle sue ricadute nella nostra vita
per la nostra salute,
sia individuale che collettiva.
Allo stesso tempo la spettacolarizzazione
della scienza nel contesto di talk show
o di eventi simili
ha finito per alimentare
quella che abbiamo chiamato infodemia.
Come ne usciamo?
Ne usciamo se restituiamo
alla scienza e alla medicina
quel ruolo centrale che dovrebbero avere,
che in parte hanno,
nelle decisioni poi politiche
di gestione della salute pubblica.
Perché è solamente grazie
alla ricerca scientifica
che scopriremo i farmaci e i vaccini
che ci proteggeranno
dalle epidemie del futuro.
Grazie.
(Applauso)